i told you a few days ago that i have
not been uh paying enough attention to
this alex jones defamation trial it's
actually a really big deal because it is
going to ultimately test the limits of
what can people with audiences and the
responsibilities that come with those
audiences myself included what are we
allowed to say about just individual
private people
before we are liable for defamation and
that is exactly what is that issue here
this is a trial happening in texas alex
jones is being sued by
parents of victims of the sandy hook
school shooting yes the one from a
decade ago
and the trial is completely unhinged
alex jones seems to have almost like a
cartoon lawyer who i i actually wonder
if it's a strategy because the lawyer is
trying to cause a mistrial that's one
aspect of this and we have video from
alex jones testimony over the last
couple of days it is wacky now we are
going to start
uh in this first clip okay
the j alex jones appears to be chewing
something during the
course of the day's events
and the judge
maya gamble
tells alex jones to stop chewing it and
then alex jones starts opening his mouth
and says that it's gauze
and she's like you're chewing on gauze
and he doesn't really say it's every
moment of this trial is bizarre take a
look at this
i i've been told that there it goes on
and
he says that he's sorry and we'd ask
that the entire apartment
let's get your gun out mr jones not gone
what is it because you're not allowed
food or gum of any kind in the program i
i had my tooth pulled a week and a half
ago and it's i had some laws earlier and
it's been causing me to have some pain
so you're chewing on your gauze would
you like to show you
so it's not really clear he says he has
he had gauze in there earlier
no i didn't want you to answer my
question no
i was massaging the hole in my mouth
with my
tongue right here i don't want to see
the inside of your mouth
there's no gum
hole
sit down
every every so
it's it's endlessly funny
but the problem is
what can she do she could eventually say
there's a mistrial but it seems like
that's only particularly good for jones
because it just delays judgment
here's another moment
in which they play a video
of alex jones saying that the plaintiff
dad
seems autistic and again the whole thing
just goes uh completely and totally off
the rails
please
i thought it was an act when i saw
someone and i'm sorry what's relevant
here is alex jones is doing this stuff
during the trial and so
not literally during the trial but i
mean in breaks and on days where he
doesn't have to be in court and so
his discussions of the trial
are coming up during the trial more and
more because the judge is not happy that
he's talking so much about the trial on
tv just because he came off his show
let's just say he's he's a he's a nice
man and
he's not an actor he is um
being manipulated by some very bad
people
they all just say because i gotta be
honest
he's slow okay
and
his ex-wife is not i don't think he's
stupid i'm just saying he's he's
i've got family members that are really
smart in a lot of ways but they're just
real kind of quiet and have this way
about them and
and and they they they move a different
pace like they're fast in some ways and
slow in others and he's
i mean i didn't cancel and act like
somebody on the spectrum and it makes me
feel like an even bigger jerk
but when i saw him like there's
something about this guy this doesn't
look and now that i've been around him
for over a week i'm like okay
now i know
folks i don't have some calculated point
just bring that up here it's just that
i'm around these people and i'm looking
at it and i'm watching what's being said
and what's
going on and it really then
makes it clear what happened
so alex jones during the trial doing
doing coverage during which he says
that it seems as though the plaintiff
dad
is uh on the autism spectrum then here
is some of alex jones actual testimony
and it just goes uh he just can't stick
to the questions that are asked it goes
completely off the rails again
anything else before we bring the
journey back
anything
all right
we're ready to have the jury back
oh and this may not even be the exact
moment that i wanted to
okay alex jones sworn in okay so he's he
brings up a piece of paper and he's
immediately told you can't have notes
and then the first question he's asked
he he just goes on a rant if you were
here when i explained to a prior witness
who brought documents with them that you
can't
look at any document for any reason
while you're testifying it's going
unless one of the lawyers or myself
instructs you to do so so i'm going to
ask you to actually just give it back to
mr reynold until
he may think you need it okay dear god
did you understand all that i did
okay
while you testify it is not a
conversation it is a question and answer
so the instructions are to let the
lawyers completely finish asking their
questions so he's told you you have to
just answer the question that's asked
and then look at how quickly that
doesn't happen i think those are all do
you understand them i do all right you
may begin mr renault
alex would you please introduce yourself
to the ladies and gentlemen of the jury
hi i'm alex jones
how are you feeling today alex
i actually feel good because i get a
chance to for the first time
say what's really going on instead of
the corporate media and high-powered law
firms manipulating what i actually did
i want to um
start by kind of
letting the jury know a little bit about
your youth and where you grew up so they
can get to know you better is that okay
okay
and you know before we do that i just do
want to say this on right here because
i've said it many times i apologize
to both sustained so mr jones one of the
instructions i just gave you is that
this is not a conversation question and
answer sure she got the monologue
without me i got it and so argumentative
with the judge yeah and and again this
all could be a strategy to try to get a
mistrial to make the plaintiffs have to
start over you have to only answer
questions that are asking you mr reynold
will ask you i'm certain all the
questions you want but you have to wait
for the question
you may proceed
okay
so then at another point during this the
topic of alex jones gravelly voice comes
up you guys know that gravelly voice
globalished internationalist trotskyite
socialist shun like obama trudeau macron
okay that's me actually so now let's get
to the actual subject matter of his
voice and then again the plaintiff's
attorney is like is there is is and
there's is there any relevance to this
so one of the things i notice uh about
you is that you have a very
uh distinctive
voice
um
very deep sort of gravelly voice uh did
your voice always sound that way no
what what happened to your voice why
does it sound the way it does
well i remember the two demonstrations
were finally erected
um and one was about
i guess about
12 13 years ago
it was actually film of its
do you have something to tie this to
anything related to this case
no no no
i'll address you if i'm talking to you
this is so that the jury can
understand who my client is
right
the jury could not possibly understand
who the client is
unless the backstory on his gravelly
voice is explained um one more really
interesting moment
there are
two
assertions
that the judge tells alex jones this is
outside the audience of the jury that he
can't say
alex jones refused to participate to
allow discovery in this trial and we
covered that meaning he refused to allow
the plaintiffs to gather the all of the
things that they he was in order to
allow
and he says during his testimony that he
allowed discovery um in addition
he claims that he is bankrupt but that's
not actually true he filed for
bankruptcy and the judge tells him you
can't keep saying that stuff
mr jones
you may not say to this jury
that you comply with discovery
that is not true
you may not say it again
you may not tell this jury that you are
bankrupt that is also not true
you may have filed for bankruptcy
i don't know that but i heard that it
doesn't put that doesn't make a person
or a company bankrupt
so um
again
she is completely correct about all of
these things
but what's the recourse is it to declare
a mistrial
and if so
everything i'm reading is that actually
helps alex jones and it hurts the
plaintiff so a completely insane trial
and uh on an upcoming live stream we may
or may not talk about it more let me
know your thoughts
one of our sponsors is zebiotix a
probiotic drink that breaks down the
byproduct of alcohol which is most
responsible for some of those rough
mornings if you drink a small bottle of
zebiotics before your first drink of
alcohol and then drink responsibly guys
please get a good night's sleep you can
enjoy the next day feeling refreshed and
ready to make the most of it sam cedar
swears by it here's how it works when
you drink a toxic byproduct of alcohol
builds up
in your unprepared gut
this by-product causes you to feel
terrible the day after drinking
z-biotics produces an enzyme like the
one your liver uses to break down the
byproduct and zibiotix is fda compliant
for safety this is a product for
responsible adults who have just a few
drinks
but they have plans tomorrow they want
to feel their best we all want to feel
our best if zebiotics doesn't work for
you you get your money back guys it's
that simple go to xebiotics.com
pacman and use the code pacman for 15
off your first order the link is down
below